Місто Кельн на заході Німеччини.
Тут мешкає донька видатного українського фізика-теоретика Лева Штрума,
якого в сталінські часи оголосили "ворогом народу".
У 1936-му, коли Олена Штрум була 13-річною дівчинкою,
до них у комунальну квартиру в Києві прийшли співробітники НКВС і взяли батька під варту.
Це було вночі. Мені наказали лежати в ліжку і не ворушитися, не вставати.
І вони пішли. Це тривало, по суті, дуже недовго.
Батька забрали – і все.
Жовтневий палац у Києві.
Місце, біля якого гинула від куль снайперів Небесна сотня.
Понад 80 років тому тут працював київський НКВС.
Олена Штрум тут востаннє бачилась із батьком.
Його розстріляли через півроку після арешту.
Дізнатися цю страшну правду їй вдалося лише тепер.
На її прохання активісти проекту "Остання адреса",
що співпрацює із товариством "Меморіал",
розшукали справу Лева Штрума в архівах СБУ.
Десь тиждень-два на це пішло.
Дуже вдячний працівнику СБУ на прізвище Смірнов,
який займався цим і зібрав усі 30 томів цієї справи.
Це велика справа, яка стосується не тільки Штрума,
а й усієї цієї організації "троцькістів", яка була страчена повністю.
Там десь 20 прізвищ, не менше.
До архівного відділу СБУ таких звернень з кожним роком стає більше.
Адже майже всі документи періоду сталінського терору нині відкриті.
Понад 99% документів, які стосуються сталінського терору,
вони є відкритими і зараз якраз із ними активно працюють дослідники,
історики і також з цими документами знайомляться родичі
осіб, які тоді загинули.
На будинку в центрі Києва, де мешкав Лев Штрум,
нещодавно встановили меморіальну табличку.
Він завідував кафедрою теоретичної фізики Київського університету
і був першим на теренах СРСР, хто обґрунтував
можливість існування частинок, що рухаються швидше за світло.
Однак, за документами НКВС, він був активним членом організації "троцькістів"
та вів контрреволюційну роботу.
У чому, згідно з паперами, сам зізнався.
В яких умовах велися допити в радянський час, усі знають.
Під тортурами.
І якщо батько підписав, одна сторінка, ось так ось, одна сторінка,
що він і те, і се, і п‘яте-десяте, і він підписався.
Ну це така, як то кажуть, взірцево-показова справа.
Коли почалося полювання на всіх, хто був якось пов'язаний із Львом Троцьким
І через те, що Лев Штрум був близьким другом Семена Семковського,
це двоюрідний брат Льва Троцького...
Його справжнє прізвище теж було Бронштейн...
Саме через це він і постраждав.
Олена Львівна показує єдине фото батька, що збереглося.
Після війни вона переїхала до Росії.
Там донька одного із корифеїв ядерної фізики
захистила кандидатську в Інституті напівпровідників.
А в дев'яностих емігрувала до Німеччини.
ї син - теж фізик, у Нідерландах, правнук - програміст.
Так вийшло, що плодами праці ані Штрума, ані його нащадків
Україна скористатись не змогла.